let's go live to Andrew Simmons who is
in London for us Andrew Boris pulling
out changes things significantly is this
now a one-horse race
well it certainly is looking that way
Boris Johnson declaring that uh
initially that it was in the National
interest that he should stand you know
coming here like a a knight in shining
armor uh leaving the sunshine and sand
behind but really there was never any
real chance of him actually doing it it
would appear because the conservative
parliamentary party just don't want that
baggage from Johnson here in Downing
Street the place of party gate the fact
that there's an investigation a
parliamentary investigation still going
on to Boris Johnson Boris Johnson he'd
be sidelined by that if he was to come
to power it was technically possible if
it was put to the whole country the
whole country is conservative membership
because he is quite popular out there
but in parliamentary terms no so he has
declared that he had 102 votes we'll
never know how many votes he had in
truth because each media organization
has been pushing uh checking out who's
who who's going to vote where the
figures according to according to Media
are anything between 20 and up to 60
votes for him but not enough not enough
for that 100 margin now the spotlight is
on uh very much on sunac sunac is has
all the right attributes it would seem
for the city he's respected in the city
he's liked by the Parliamentary party
some have doubts about him because of
the way he backstabbed Boris Johnson he
went for him along with many other
people many of other people who at the
time were only talking two months ago
who at the time were actually saying oh
look you've got to stand down you've got
to stand down have this time thought
they were backing the right horse and
voted were prepared to vote for him so
this is a big big funny old mix of
British politics but the bottom line is
we might see an announcement of the new
prime minister on Monday it could be
hours away because there is no need to
actually go to the National men
membership of the conservative party if
there's only one Contender who qualifies
so that that would be what's called a
coronation don't start thinking there's
anything involvement of King Charles III
and that's that's a totally separate
issue coronation meaning we don't need
to go to the membership to confirm uh
what's actually happening so so yes this
is the situation we could have believe
it or not a new prime minister here in
Downing streets within a matter of
matter of hours the announcement and
then a matter of 24 hours uh going to
King Charles III uh to uh to actually uh
be asked a bit former government we
understand that King Charles is
available uh I'm not sure that's Windsor
or Buckingham Palace but available over
the next 24 hours for that to happen
so just go through the timeline for us
in more detail Andrew uh is there still
a chance that Penny mordant could gather
more support by lunchtime
it's highly unlikely
um the figure we've got now for her is
something over 20 votes now there could
be quite a lot of votes uh gained from
people uh who were going to back Boris
Johnson uh who don't like who don't like
the prospect of sunac uh being prime
minister uh however those numbers aren't
likely to be that big we understand
people like to back winners in the
conservative party especially if their
names might become public so it does
look as if a lot of votes are
transferring to sooner and sunak is in a
good place already having gone past the
the number of 100 minimum in terms of
timings as I say 13g is the close of
nominations if the modern does some
spectacular
um uh magical uh increase in her support
then there would be a first ballot
results at 17 GMT and then we've been in
a position where the house the whole
thing has to go to the country with an
online vote but expect
very much so soon act to win this okay
thank you for that Andrew Simmons there
for us in London